hot breath so when you talk about taking
it to
like the page and you're like maybe i
need to rework it on the page uh
wayne flake asks like what is your
favorite writing technique and maybe
make that plural in terms of like what
are some of your go-to
writing techniques to kind of put your
jokes through a checklist type deal
yeah well when i started uh
my main technique was to write every day
uh
sit down for two hours
uh and that was a block of time that
worked for me it's it's different for
everyone but i would encourage people to
go for two hours
because sometimes in that first hour
um nothing really comes you know
sometimes you're sitting there and maybe
just
a few sentences or whatever but if you
know i'm in this chair
for two hours my phone is off i'm not
looking you know
and i write with a pen and paper too uh
mostly
because i don't want the distraction of
potentially logging onto the internet or
looking at my facebook or whatever else
uh so
for me pen and paper means it's just me
i'm in this chair i'm with my thoughts
and
i know i'm here for two hours i don't
care what happens i don't care what
distractions come up i'm just
staying and writing and if you do that
for
you know five days a week for uh
a month for two months for six months
really what you're doing is you're
learning your voice
you're learning your process you're
spending intimate time with yourself
which is important you know because uh
when you go up in front of a crowd you
are making a request for their
attention you're asking for their focus
to be on you so what have you done to
earn that
have you put in the time have you put in
the hours do you know what you have to
say
because if you don't know what you have
to say and you don't know who you are
uh you know it begs the question do you
really deserve to ask
a room of people to listen now you know
i mean
of course you do deserve it because
you're a human being and you're
you're offering your thoughts and you're
you're offering
you know um your creativity so
that has its own merit but i'm talking
about in the grand scheme of like being
a professional
and getting everything yeah i'm not just
talking about an open mic at a coffee
shop you know
don't get me wrong everybody has the
right to get up on stage that's great
but i'm talking about really sitting
with yourself and discovering
who you are um so that takes time and
you really have to
give your craft the proper respect and
the proper time
so over years uh that developed another
thing that i did
um was early on study everybody
um whether it's people that you're
working with but study the greats
study richard pryor george carlin uh
everyone moms maybe uh you know everyone
that you can think of
uh bob newhart uh stephen wright um
on up through uh chappelle you know uh
just study everybody who
really uh owns their craft you know
and another thing that i would do is
when i had my jokes
sometimes i would recite them in other
people's styles
i would say to myself like how would
stephen wright deliver this joke
how would uh george carlin
deliver this joke because what that does
is those people have very
distinct styles right stephen wright is
kind of low-key
deadpan uh dry um
carlin is is more high energy more
physical
so sometimes you know like sam kinnison
whoever it is
think of different styles uh and
you know it's really just an exercise
for you to say like
am i getting everything out of this joke
that i can be that that fits my style
you know
as as you're figuring out your style
because if you try it in
um whoever's you know uh
fill in the blank if you try it in gary
goldman style or whoever
uh maybe you'll find one little moment
in the joke that wasn't there before
maybe a pause maybe a facial gesture
maybe something physical
maybe you'll be louder because you tend
to be quiet or vice versa
so yeah i think exploring different
people's voices when you're starting out
is a good mental kind of
exploration